so here's the facebook [ __ ] now they're
changing their name to meta
i'm old enough to remember when facebook
was you know
college kids trying to get laid by the
way if facebook was still functioning
like that we wouldn't need cool mom to
be driving kids around getting them
slammed but because facebook is no
longer functioning as a dating app for
children it is now functioning as a
place for elderly people to scream into
the void to post pictures of their dead
dogs to talk about their knee operations
and and to start you know these long
threads where people are trying to
educate each other on all manner of
topics
they and they think the problem with
facebook is misinformation all social
media is misinformation whether it's
russia or your mother-in-law everybody
on facebook is lying
and so you have a whistleblower and this
[ __ ] comes out and facebook is now
changing their name to meta which is
weird because a restaurant long island i
like did that still good restaurant
facebook fails to moderate harmful
content in developing countries what did
this whistleblower do
why is she
what is the big deal here
basically she's saying that their
focusing they they care more about
profit than the safety of their users so
they allow uh hateful content and hate
groups and people like that to spread
tons of misinformation that gets people
but those are their users
hate groups are your users
if someone's starting a hate group on
your platform they are a user are they
not
quote facebook was aware that maids were
being sold on its platform
internal documents show that facebook
admitted it was quote under enforcing
on confirmed abusive activity when it
failed to take action after filipino
maids complained of being abused and
sold on the platform according to the
associated press quote in our
investigation domestic workers
frequently complained to their
recruitment agencies of being locked up
in their homes starved forced to extend
their contracts indefinitely unpaid and
repeatedly sold to other employers
without their consent one facebook
document read
in response agencies commonly told them
to be more agreeable it's not horrible
advice
so what is it is it facebook's fault
that people are using facebook to buy
and sell maids
yeah and like the january 6 stuff and
should i post a status right now anybody
want a made
i'm going to post a status and see if it
gets taken down
let's test this right now
i'm gonna do it to see if it actually
works here okay
i'm posting your status right now
what's on your mind
does anyone want a maid
i have one
chained up in my
chained up
in my basement
she will work
you can hit her
and then under it i'm gonna write test
see that
does anyone want a maid i have one
chained up in my basement she will work
you can hit her test
post
let's see what happens okay
i was unaware of this that people were
buying and selling mates is this only in
the philippines
uh yeah so they're really bad at
managing things in other countries
because they can't
speak the language very well so then
there's like hate groups in like india
against like muslims you are determined
to sell a maid aren't you gonna sell a
maid
i mean this is the reality
how many roadblocks do we have to put up
before people realize
that if you were what do you mean the ai
struggles with non-english languages
isn't this a highly sophisticated
artificial intelligence system for like
english yeah they can't understand
filipino apparently not it says they
support 50 languages when in reality
most of those languages get a tiny
fraction of the safety systems that
english gets so they kind of with the
other countries they just kind of let
them run amok
is the status okay did they take it down
it's still up nice see maybe this is a
problem
the wi-fi is not good here
i have five likes
does anyone want a maid i have one
chained up in my basement she will work
you can hit her
see look like myanmar they couldn't
identify hate speech in ethiopia
languages
uh so there was no safeguards for those
countries
well what are they doing that's so bad
i don't care about hate speech i'm more
concerned with the selling and the of
the maids
well yeah that's that's the worst thing
to me don't you think the maids are like
can we stop focusing on the hate speech
i'm in a closet
i'm getting hit with a broom
doesn't that make more sense yeah
facebook's algorithm mistakenly banned
the hashtag referencing the quote
al-aqsa mosque in jerusalem's old city
because they thought it represented the
militant group al-aqsa martyrs brigade
who are we like we are like them
uh an armed offshoot is a secular fatah
party document show a lot of our fans
are in a hawk some artists brigade
the company later apologized but the
accidental removal of content serves as
a shining example i love that serves as
a shining example for how the social
media giant's algorithms can stifle
political speech due to language
barriers and lack of resources outside
of north america
so this whole thing's about languages
yeah something i smell a rat
i don't agree with this
this can't be about
that you don't understand
what
does anyone ever made in filipino
language in telugu or whatever the hell
they speak
i want to beat my maid in filipino
nobody understands what that is
hey my maid's dead anyone got another
one so as long as i write that in
non-english i'm okay
something's wrong but what about the
whistleblower people say she's a creep
because the greenwald made a point a lot
of this seems to be like
okay we take uh the power away from
these tech oligopolies but then who gets
it the government does anyone feel
better with the government
running the show you don't think they're
gonna ban you they'll ban you
this is her frances haugen
where's she from
uh let me see here
i know she's in europe right now doing
this whole thing
this woman is a uh
is she like snowden is she gonna have to
leave the country she's from iowa city
is zuckerberg gonna have her whacked
i mean zach why don't you grow some
balls and have this woman killed
truly let's play with this creep this
creep sad with the sweet baby rays
barbecue sauce on the back and i said
that he's this guy he doesn't you know
sweet baby he doesn't know that it goes
on the food he's just trying to like be
a human being but hey zuck why don't you
grow some balls and have this
whistleblower [ __ ] whacked have her
killed
have this [ __ ] killed
she's [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
so this is a stop being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and have her killed
act like a [ __ ] boss
why don't you ever act like a boss you
always go into congress and you're
always [ __ ]
pale and weird and [ __ ] equivocating
get this [ __ ] stomped out american
history x style make her bite the curb
remember that scene bite the curb and
then with the boot
do it to this [ __ ]
i want you to watch or get killed zuck
like khashoggi was getting tortured in
the mbs watched it again allegedly no
issues with them allegedly he was
watching it i want zuckerberg to watch
this when we get killed let's see what
he has to say i'm on his side here a
little bit so this is the rebrand with
uh meta so this is the sneak peek at the
facebook metaverse now
meta
is going to be a better place to sell
the maids
is that what we're
because they're creating a world where
maids will be sold
seamlessly
okay here we go i need a maid
are you coming yeah just gotta find
something to wear
all right perfect
oh hey mark hey what's going on
what's up ma whoa we're here's the deals
that big creature is the maid
they don't show the real maid because
she's bruised and bloody
so what zuckerberg has done
is he has an avatar for his maid
so that it disguises the substantial
physical damage he's done to her
continue this is brilliant i respect
this guy and for anyone confused this is
through vr goggles through like you know
right because if you were to look at it
in actuality you would just see a
bleeding filipino maid
uh-huh who made this place that's
awesome who made this place the next
crater i met in l.a what happened to the
place it is
amazing this is cool this is like vr of
course it's me hey you know i had that
is there a wasn't there a maze i hear
knocking in the
in a uh garage what happened in the mail
you were bluffing
i don't know i think she got sick
the maid got sick let's call her she's
not around anymore stop asking questions
about the [ __ ] maid hey should we
deal you in
sorry i'm running late but you've got to
see what we're checking out there's an
artist going around soho hiding ar
pieces for people to find wow
3d street there's some there's people in
the philippines going around hiding
maids
are you guys up on that or no
were you just concerned about the
let's see this is like after 9 11 when
they're like the cia doesn't understand
arabic i'm like no they understand it
fine when they plan the attack
they're like well they they the cia
didn't know anything about the attackers
they don't speak arabic i said i think
they spoke it well when they were
training the hijackers in [ __ ]
arizona
anyway in florida contact us for brand
deals